hallo clixoom hallo mein werden zwei
fragen nämlich die erste wehr wasser
also verhältnis von carolin kebekus und
die zweite wer würdest du sie eventuell
zurück dessen
also die carolin kebekus ist bei
wochenshow und wochenschau macht gerne
sich lustig über andere und ich habe mir
das gemisch angehört und ich finde es
gar nicht so wahr weil noch im schosse
sendung die gerne leute mal über die
leute lustig machen und was sich bei dem
video beeindruckt hat dass sie das so
schön ist die carolin kebekus und
ja wenn sie die liebes ansage haben mich
machen will dann kennst du noch
schreiben können und
ich bin ich zu einem bisher zu dass sie
zurück dass das ist einfach fernsehen
medien und also ich fand es also ich
fand ihr aussehen und so schön
genau und liebe größeren carolin kebekus